[Music]
two weeks after takeoff's death offset
is ready to open up about his unbearable
grief that feels like a nightmare you
know you get to share life-changing
moments with people who you change your
life for following takeoff's Memorial on
Friday his cousin and Miko's bandmate
breaks his silence sharing messages on
Instagram explaining that he's been
searching for the right words to say but
there aren't any that will suffice
[Music]
alongside a carousel of videos and pics
offset writes in part quote the pain you
have left me with is unbearable I've
been going to sleep and waking up hoping
that all of this is a dream but it's
reality and reality feels like a
nightmare we won we got each other back
he got my back then we all won yeah so
it's like we hanging on to ourselves
that's all we got offset continues quote
I know someone with a soul like yours is
in heaven now I hope you can see how
much we love you and miss you you're
left a hole in my heart that will never
be filled right hand on the Bible I
swear I won't tell you I swear quavo
takeoff's uncle and also a member of
Miko's echoed those sentiments over the
weekend sharing quote this whole time
I've been trying to figure what you
really are to me because nephew wasn't
it now I finally get it you are our
angel you are affecting culture across
pop music everywhere who doesn't
understand who needs to know you know we
all need to know if you you know I'm
saying if you're part of the culture and
a part of hip-hop and music you need to
know cardi B was by her husband offset
side to take off celebration of life
where Justin Bieber Drake Chloe Bailey
CeeLo Green were just some of many stars
who gathered in Atlanta whenever he
would take his Shades off he had this
love no matter what was going on around
us he was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open
[Music]
rapper Da Brat shared video from outside
the venue
rip takeoff
Lucci bro
damn
we love you bro
cardi also paid tribute over the weekend
writing in part quote the impact you had
in this world was so considerable and we
have struggled to grasp this tragedy
adding that she is heartbroken but
grateful for all the precious memories
they share all our families is one we
sit together we eat together you know
what I'm saying it's like what better
way else to do it or with your family
you know what I'm saying day one she
ain't got to worry about nobody coming
through the press and doing nothing flaw
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying we
ain't got no problem each other and only
us you know what I'm saying foreign
[Music]